[Applause]
we now face severe global headwinds
caused by russia's appalling war in
ukraine
and the aftermath of covet
now is the time to tackle the issues
that are holding britain back
we will transform britain into an
aspiration nation with high-paying jobs
safe streets and where everyone
everywhere has the opportunities they
deserve
good afternoon nice to meet you
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
i'm proud
to have discharged the promises i made
to my party when you were kind enough to
choose me winning the biggest majority
since 1987 the biggest share of the vote
since 1979 delivering brexit delivering
our manifesto commitments including by
the way including social care together
we have laid foundations that will stand
the test of time whether by taking back
control of our laws or putting in vital
new infrastructure great solid masonry
on which we will continue to build
together
paving paving the path of prosperity now
and for future generations
and i will be supporting liz truss and
the new government every step of the way
thank you all very much thank you and
goodbye thank you